hello everyone Welcome to our third open
language design review of the day this
is part of the version 14 season
um
and right now we are looking at video
image image do we get audio as well oh
my gosh got audio as well
okay video
what's happened to video in the cloud by
the way
because it just wasn't working
it should be work there is one corner
case of files that are within the layout
that is still problematic
but as a general statement it should
work
it should be working now or it should be
working in 14. now
it's been working for a while
didn't work for me as I said there is a
corner case of files that exist within
the mathematical layout so unfortunately
that covers some of the example data
that we have
um
but in general if you create a video
or grab the video from some other source
we don't have any issues
so if I say something like manipulate
plot sine X plus a
x 0 10
a
I don't know zero five
then that hopefully will create for me
and manipulate
okay now I say what do I say how do I
make a video of this yes
video of that
yep
oh well that's a grind for a while is
this going to work do you think
should I think there is some issue with
progress indicators in general in the
cloud
uh can somebody Trace that please no no
the details of debt could somebody Trace
that please who's pmming here
Eli I believe that there is a ticket or
a bug report for it somewhere
try an animation video example too I'm
not trying anymore it crashed
oh
all right
so it's not working I think this is what
happened to me before
okay Carlo could that as well be the
progress indicator
it could be I mean this guy just need to
trace it
okay
okay what am I supposed to look at here
uh two or 3D video
this is just general statements about
there
this is probably a little bit
overstated from where we are right now
should have probably Paradise broke us
back
sorry about that
okay so we look at the cow from every
angle yeah
how do we determine I mean so if I say
uh so if I make a 3D object here
I'm just going to save this in a
reasonable place
that's not what I want to say that I
want to save it in that story notes
um
where should I say this image processing
I must have an image processing
I guess I'm just going to make a folder
here called design reviews but I really
would appreciate if people would
actually put it in here
get some pm to put it in here
so that we
keep it in the same place
um I I prefer you pull them when we have
the meeting because all right they're
updated to the very last
um
okay
what's it doing
oh my God this is so slow
should I be I mean
is it just because we're doing a lot of
stuff all in one go that this is so slow
most of it is rice rice
so how do we make what resolution
machine are you on
very high resolution yeah
so you're getting high resolution
rasters well is that what we want all
the time
um you can control it by the raster size
you don't know to control it because
um Sandra on our live stream is
commenting for tour video as a
recommendation when you do a 10 times
zoom in what you see it is that the size
is now changing linearly over time but
that means the zoom rate is no is not
constant which looks unpleasant
what
if you do a 10 times zoom in
yeah let's just see what this does
okay it's amusing it's not dramatic but
it's amusing
um I think you should understand what
Sandra was saying 10 times zoom in for
tour video I think I understand zooming
in
um uh the how we zoom in is not linear
Zoom
right if you if you specify uh as a
weight of the frame at time zero and it
would have to frame at time t
uh how we get from one to two
is just by I think linearly
interpolating
the width but that means the zoom level
is not uh
linearly sounds wrong right take a look
at it
makes sense
I think it's specific for case to case
I'm sure it is wrong in some case but it
is not wrong in other cases I'm not sure
if there is a general statement I want
to make before I understand more okay
just look at it and see what
animation video of U of T and T goes
from zero to one
I'm upset the duck rushed and I don't
understand why we looked at we'll look
back on that but I think that
is kind of a corner case yeah so that's
what I expect
why does this have
why does it have the banding here why
isn't it at the top I think that's the
control HTML element that we rely on
that is how we can play back video
without involving the kernel
if you play and move your mouse out it
might go away after a second or so
oh I see
well that's cute I mean that's a
microscopic video but
okay so look at these tours I haven't I
mean I've seen them in Prototype mode
which see up there there were sort of
pre-tours named you can specify of
course
um
you know every you know
um key points you know a key camera
views and whatnot those other ones don't
work those are still be ironed out oh
man that's that's the easy ones
those are the easy ones right the
fully rotate is implemented
in your version of projects what's it
going to do by default
I think rotate is fine
okay
pan would be useful if you have a very
very wide object
and that's not most of the cases
yeah Zoom wouldn't be that exciting yeah
I think rotate is the best
you know I'm about to make use of all
this video capabilities for some
video I'm making for some talk I'm
supposed to give
uh
so you're probably hearing from me well
that will be good feedback
right it's going to be a little
complicated because I'm I'm trying to
make well there's several different
things going on I'm actually I'm
surprised you haven't heard yet from
Richard at The Institute
um
because he's making some very
complicated movie with hypographs and
Etc et cetera Etc
uh well you'll hear from him
his thoughts on should I tell him to
contact you caller yeah why not I mean
if anything General mailing lists would
be the best Stephen and if there is Need
for like quick uh progression like the
TV replacement rocket shot is usually
pretty good
okay can somebody communicate that
um do I need to communicate that Eli
could you please write a little email
and I'll forward it on sure thank you
okay
subtitle like this
okay what font does it use for the
subtitles
don't don't have right it necessarily a
default it's uh usually either within
the file itself or as a site I say I see
and it's symbolic it's not like uh it
has we can store style information that
you know if the font doesn't exist or
whatever uh
some default will be chosen by the
player
all right I have no idea what these
Fades look like
scroll to the option section
I try to visualize it in that transition
effect so no no transition just goes
from one to the next
and then if you have fade which is the
next one you have some kind of an
overlay like that and then an idea
whether it looks reasonable or not
ugh
click to download the
resource Define
you don't need to read badly
and now play again
can I resize this or not
they're actively no
why did that flip
so quickly stopped just before the end
there was something really was happening
there with interactivity
well looks reasonable but I don't I
don't understand Fades very well
I mean it seems like you have multiple
many fade options yeah I don't think
those will be necessary just because
we're not dealing with something like
sound that has a logarithmic perception
we we're looking at pixel values so I
think the linear one will be the default
choice and I'm not sure there will be
much need to tweak that but we do have
for several curves
have what
several curves we have support for all
of those kind of fadings of the
intensity of the two curves yes
images intensity of images yeah
Sandra's asking why is it possible to
rotate
dodecahedron a 200 Hertz in the front
end but rasterizing it isn't even close
to that speed oh that's a very good
question
um unfortunately
um
the front end is not very fast at
rasterizing uh it needs to first of all
it needs to figure out how big the thing
is which from what I understand and keep
in mind I'm not a front-end expert here
um figuring out the size of the cell
that is being rasterized is expensive
and then all of those pixel values need
to be stirred and transferred over
mathlang which is also not the fastest
thing
um they're also doing the wrong thing I
mean look I think that there's something
fishy there's something fishy about that
whole thing because if we if we you know
Dr John false about that he will be sure
but first of all you know there's
something about finding the size we know
the freaking size here if we're
rasterizing a whole image we know the
size well I'm sure that is true but
clearly there is some subtlety that John
will know better how to explain than I
do do you understand what I'm saying
yeah okay I also that was my assumption
too that's what I asked to John as well
can we skip this calculating this size
and also in modern times we have all of
these foreign function interface
mechanisms and so on maybe we don't need
to transfer anything
through you know wstp or whatever
yeah these are questions
transparent to an external file anyway
no no it's a transferring data right
from
um the front end to the kernel Through
Math link
that is I know why doesn't the front end
just open some ffi connection to
something which is dumping data into a
file I would agree and those are all
rasterized improvements that we would
definitely welcome but it's not
rasterized that wouldn't be rasterized
there'll be something special for videos
sure sure
because you're going to throw it into a
file yeah you're an encoder through a
video encoder
no it would not go through rasterize
ever it would do the same thing it still
would need to pass through the kernel
the front end doesn't have access to
encoders
it cannot write directly to a video file
well then then you may need to write
something that has some separate little
program that just goes through the
encoders to a video file
yeah I mean that sounds potentially but
I thought we did write something
actually
right yeah that's what I was thinking
that that is for reading not for writing
well I guess we can add writing
right so then the idea would be don't go
don't ever go I mean it's crazy to go
through the kernel that's why this is so
unbelievably slow
come on guys we can avoid this
thank you I think that definitely we
need to talk to John about I I'm feeling
not qualified enough to see if saved can
can we get this okay this should
probably be on the global project list
kind of a critically important thing
given that we're trying to support video
and you just spent you know a couple of
years working on this let's make sure we
don't you know the final link isn't
there's totally broken
makes sense
you can why don't we bring that back to
another meeting with me
yeah I mean we do have also a meeting
with John regularly we can see what he
thinks of this Avenue I think so I I
think it's going to need me grinding on
the engineering because it sounds like
people are confused
I think the idea is pretty clear
well it is well if you have you haven't
done it for the last two years so I have
to believe it wasn't that clear
no I mean the idea is clear just what we
the conclusion was that is not a viable
solution okay I don't believe you that's
why I think I need to be in let us have
a chat with John and we can look back
with you if needed thank you okay if you
if you haven't actually solved it loop
back with me sure okay I'm certain this
can be done
okay
segment understand okay
that's Sam a group mentioned in the
previous meeting yeah yeah okay so what
should I look at here
all those functions should have
documentation you see the examples below
it's hard to locate in that big
this is
yeah these are background removal
examples
So currently what you see on 14
um Sam based background removal we're
grabbing a hold of the boundary around
the image ignore the artifact the one
pixel raw artifacts but from that we're
trying to segment outside from inside
yeah well it's doing really well yep
wow
yeah it's great but this is one flavor
of Sam
the other two functions we're
introducing or we're proposing to
introduce one is a global segmentation
animation components the other one is
really similar to remove background but
instead of returning an image with an
alpha Channel Returns the mask
just Alpha Channel
Okay so
uh this is really old Stephen you did an
update I did update so I don't know
what's going on
so you tell me
I just ran an update okay
[Music]
I don't know how your scripts work but
my version
has an illustration in their notes and
starts with then I I just asked in the
last meeting for somebody to please
check this apparently they didn't do it
so what should I be seeing I mean
okay
unless you an image what was it image
components what was that yeah
well that's what I've got this is very
old
maybe more than a week old
okay well I just updated
can update again right now Roger can you
confirm you see an illustration maybe
there
yeah let me double check
oh I need to update too because you
just did it right so
okay it says it's up to date
okay says it's up to date
so I don't know what's going on
okay
so you want to email me the file or what
something something's wrong with this
it's not correctly updating so let's not
waste time on this
you want me to send you a file I can I
want you to send me the image components
documentation file the one that is not
updated
yeah I have the I get the updated file
from okay I don't know what the heck's
going on so can somebody please get with
the other Roger I can work with Roger if
you want me to please do it
I just sent you the file
okay
I don't know how this could possibly be
wrong and I worry that it's going to
spray all kinds of stupid old files into
the layout
yeah that's happened before I know it's
happened before
supposedly because that you know one of
the machines had a disk filled up but
let's make sure it doesn't happen again
I'm not getting this mail yet
now Sam is slow we're working to see if
he can make the neural network faster
the first time we need to download the
network this is is that Sam this one
here yes
okay so it's unbelievably slow
yep
we're hoping we can cut that by a factor
of two or something but it is going to
be so many times so how are we going to
deal with this
we're shipping h100 to each customer
no no seriously Roger how are we going
to deal with this
I think that they're doing I mean well
so I haven't seen them honestly have a
performance goal yeah but the issue is
how's anybody ever going to know that
it's not just bad
is there a progress monitor for it yes
um
but what are we going to use for default
and and are we using gpus are we are we
using GPS
so why not
um
that
in 14-0 the Onyx implementation will
support core ml which means we can use
it on Max then then it will use it by
default yeah that will be great yep yeah
okay so so please
so Cuda for
non-max
for ML for Max I think we should try
that
that's a sort of a faster information so
is this the CPU timing or what
CPU timing yes okay so it'll be much
faster with gpus yes so but but I think
it would be good
to invent a scheme
for Progress monitors so one of the
lessons that we've learned in recent
years is
you know reevaluation works in the
following sense for example you you
loaded wfr you've got an out of date
version
okay it says you've got an out-of-date
version it says press here to to update
okay but it gives a result anyway with
the older version making sense but it
seems to work just fine for people you
press the update and you run it again if
you want that
see what I'm saying so in this case what
I would suggest is it has something
which says you know performance goal and
then it might have a pull down in the in
the in the progress monitor or something
um
uh you know if it was a quality it could
be like a a button that's like stop and
run at lower quality
that would be interesting yep
something so that way we could default
it to high quality mostly people when
people are using it interactively
they'll just see it you know it might
grind for a while but they'll at least
see what's going on
and that way they'll know to change your
code and so on
um
all right what else do we have to see
about this image components
nothing much here design wise is
controversial on unless you want to
discuss this is a new function wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
I don't understand how
this
this is a labeling function but just
like it reminds me of of uh connected
graph components
versus
you know what I'm saying what one of
them actually gives graphs and the other
gives just the labels
right
I would like to get something which is
you know the image component images so
to speak
I don't want to get all my horses out as
a list
I mean I understand there'll be
incomplete horses but that's okay
see what I'm saying rather than a label
Matrix which I then have to mess around
with
would we wait for that for annotations
to come I'm guessing for team one and
then maybe we can even embed that into
the same image but you'll still have to
mess with that no it's not good it's not
good that's not what list of images yeah
that's what we want because in many
cases in many cases if those horses were
better separated that's exactly what I
want just like in facial features we get
a list of faces which is very good very
useful
for one thing I'm thinking it's going to
be a very much bloated result you're you
know if if you have so many components I
think I have an example of some Tomatoes
um
maybe in another but then how many
images are going to be coming back well
but remember each image is smaller
I mean they have bounding boxes
oh the puppy is a small puppy you know
see what I'm saying and then we lose the
relative location of the puppy is that
useful
well it's the same thing as facial
features we should do it the same way we
do it right a different set of
properties
and maybe some some criteria for
selecting what components to return that
I think that would be a good idea but I
think that's a really useful function I
think it's much more useful than this
function with labeling experts
um you have proposals for the name I
wasn't able I don't really like image
components being this this thing that
does something that's basically very
very expert based
what are the other names in this area I
mean there's there's things like
morphological components and so on
right yes what do we have there what do
we have all the all the segmentation
functions that return the label Matrix
and with components now we have other
functions that end with components as
well
clustering components image foresting
components
grow cut components segmentation
oh
one of those segmentation algorithms
that honestly never worked well
we should probably obsolete this
function
I if I was thinking about the same thing
I mean we should probably
you know for some of these functions we
should just at least nominally obsolete
them and just say it's been superseded
by image components or whatever
okay and a lot of these things that were
you know algorithm specific so to speak
which can now be done better with
machine learning
why not plan to obsolete them
sure
some of them
still probably have value for uh two two
reasons why one speed and two being so
very well defined and deterministic
options
maybe they should just okay
sure I can see that
um
because I think that for x and then to
get documented as method in the method
framework for documentation indeed which
will be good basically this page more or
less you know just be formatted
yep
I think it's a much better idea because
I think muddying things up where
somebody says I'm Gonna Learn image
processing oh my gosh I have to learn
forest in components I don't know what
the heck that is they don't have to
learn it or John vase
yeah
Roger's favorite
99 nobody knows what it is but I ask
them if they know what it is yeah I've
had 100 success rate or failure rate
depending on how you
view it I think Christopher likes that
function you could try asking him what
it is I think he would know okay I'm I'm
telling you that the functionality that
segmentation works this one I could
never get a good segmentation out of it
but yeah okay it works right well maybe
it should be the default option for
default method for binarize and and I do
think that this idea of of when anything
is at all slow having a progress monitor
with this you know buttoning and so on
to indicate that there might be a faster
method okay so we need to figure out
and I I don't know what
so maybe I can this is this is more of a
brainstorm thing but maybe you guys have
thought about this too
I wonder
you know so several editing tools
kind of like a you know Photoshop or
something like that
they allow you to do like a little piece
of an image very quickly so you can see
what it is
so but I don't know exactly how to
reproduce a workflow like that
um and I think that something similar
might be useful for video you don't do
the full video you do such a little
piece of it you can say what that's what
you want type thing
yes
but I don't know in a rebel exactly how
one does that you know well I mean the
one thing that will be useful to see
is things
uh
you know is is seeing the thing like
we do with image do we do it let me
sometimes we do it certainly with the
version of that that I was using
um
for that blog post about cats
uh you can see the image build up and I
could imagine a situation where
you know where you'd see the image so to
speak I don't know you know
where for example
the progress monitor would show the
image building up
does that make any sense
yeah but I don't I'm not sure that
may not be doable here Sandra is
commenting that that um a reason for
having these method-based functions is
that you want something deterministic
that doesn't change everywhere yeah
because of a new near all that
yeah that's right but but I mean that's
I think where you set a method option
because you know you've got a choice
um
uh
huh it's not just commenting the find
image shapes is great but it will be
good to open up the hidden options which
he appears to have found custom
threshold cover threshold
ER sander is digging in yeah
that's good but I mean how
why those are those are controls for for
how the image Shapers gets found
I actually don't remember all of these
okay
I I'm assuming yeah I'm assuming they're
all
um selection criteria this is
pathetically under documented like but
we have we have plans to updating this
anyways right okay let's come back to
the the
image the segmentation label versus yeah
I mean
it's so horrible to say component images
as well as image components that's just
too horrible
but I think ending with images
or features for that matter
image component features
I don't know it makes me think I'm going
to get a list of features I mean a list
of numerical feature vectors
is there a way to use the label Matrix
to pick out that sub-image
yeah we have component measurements you
can pass through it both the image and
label Matrix and say I want this
sub-image for label 5 or
actually maybe maybe the majority of the
work could be put there to make sure I
thought about that I thought about it
but the problem is by the time you have
this thing you've got to feed the fun
the the Imogen twice
see what I'm saying it makes this for
merge components but this image here
does not contain all the information so
you need the original image as well as
the mask component measurements can take
that right
it has to take both things right right
so we already lost the game
I'm saying you can't do pure sequential
function type flow
so we really want something where where
out of this comes
um but so label the label is also
category it's it's categories basically
right it's finite number of categories
and
um
do are they they're always integers for
us obviously since we stick them in in
an image or an array yeah
um
no but I mean look facial features is a
good case
as a good sample of how to do this
right so I mean I like facial features
I've used it you know
see isn't that nice
and and here we could we could have
things like you know we can have things
like the location and so on
well if you get out the sub image you we
could that's just a sub rectangle in the
Big Image right so we could say how
where it's relatively positioned if you
need to plus we could which is what we
do for facial features
we do we do we have I mean there's the
nose points you know hit it on the nose
but so somewhere here is bounding box
well that's the bounding box but you
need to of the face
oh in the beginning okay then that's
exactly what we need yeah yeah it's the
exact same model yep
now I don't understand image Contents I
thought I was gonna say
I like this correct
so I don't understand why we don't just
put this into image contents
what does image contents do you got two
dogs here
yep gives a label
gives a data set of well that's nice
exactly what we need except for the fact
that it needs to use Sam
oh with Sam we don't know what each
component is we don't know it's a dog
ask something else
it might be unknown so what right
this looks great to me this has exactly
what we need it's got the image and the
bounding box
and even a probability
then that might be there might be two
probabilities there that might the
probability for the concept I'm not sure
that the you know
the default here yeah I mean
this looks fine I mean much of the time
we will be able to resolve what it is
some of the time we won't
this is truly the right should we should
we return components that we can tell
what it is no you said it can be unknown
I don't know you have to try some things
there I mean it could be let's try yeah
it could be that that most of the time
you can resolve it it could be that it's
useful to it could be that we should
suppress by default things which we
can't identify because they because
they're kind of silly because they're
just like the you know one the left poor
of the dog type thing and that that's
not enough dog to consider it a Content
element I haven't questioned it and
maybe I missed so image components does
the segmentation doesn't it really
necessarily just do rectangles right
exactly correct it's all segmentation so
how would that fit in image contents
maybe I missed I don't know I don't know
maybe it needs a mask as well I don't
know whether image contents has a mask
but it certainly could have with this
technology image contents doesn't I was
imagining if he injected Sam into image
contents it would mask out that sub
image exactly the shape of the segment
itself
right
I mean in other words that could be a
list of masks or a list of masked out
images it would absolutely Master out
images that's what we want yeah an
additional element and disassociation
that's a must image or something
yeah look at the image and the mask
image see what I'm saying damage the
image fragment and the masked image yeah
and he could still have the bounding box
because why not and yeah additional
element
I think this should be put in image
contents
or Sam based development was longer than
what you see now for 14.
um and I think we should continue on
that I don't think how much more we can
squeeze into 14 at this point but
obviously yeah I mean look
if this is removed background this is
the result from remove background right
yep yeah so that's nice that's a good
result but I mean you know I don't know
whether we can get this into 14 but this
is where this should go this image
contents thing is is the place to put it
I think okay
I mean think about the design but it
seems right to me
and you don't want anything like image
components that just Returns the label
Matrix no you have that if you want to
but it's for Xbox okay nobody else wants
it naming wise is that a fine name to
you I don't like it very much I think
it's way too General
um alternatively I think we're proposing
if you go back to that notebook I sent
you uh semantic components
oh
no that's terrible I mean semantics
don't do that it could be anything right
semantic from
yeah don't do that that's a stupid idea
Okay so
well what kind of image components is it
anything
yeah
I mean look why does the dog
you know why are the dogs a component
and the and the stick is not
well this one is in remove background
but if you look at it yeah if you scroll
down examples of image components things
are separated better
well
uh in the notebook in the back Center
like that horse the puppy
well
yeah I mean the nose got separated I
would not call that semantic components
when the nose is separated sure
um
we did think about and and still maybe
time to put it in anyways
um use the semantic segmentation
networks that we have in the repo and
put it also in image components
I understand what is this thing I
thought this was a semantic segmentation
Network what is it if it isn't that it
is a very general purpose segmentation
Network the name is segment anything
model yeah okay okay okay
probably works like our brains work
now they kept the syntax so far very
simple so that it has it allows us to
add more things
uh more method methods for different
networks or models algorithms whatever
pipe beating some other things then for
foresting components okay yeah I mean
method Arrow whatever
I just don't like these label matrices
very much I mean they're just they're a
horrible workflow
except for people I mean this is this is
it's the same thing as you're doing Lu
decomposition or something and you stuff
the two parts The Matrix into the same
thing because all you ever had in
Fortran was a was an array you know it
was a matrix like array
it's the same type of thing this is the
same you know somebody has an you know
their data structure is an image so they
stick numbers into an array
I just don't think it's actually the
right thing but
but I was also thinking that we should
we should think a little bit about the
workflow for these label matrices like
if I could
mask on five
you know that's the only thing that
shows in my image then it was beat much
nicer yeah a bit more useful right and I
I just think about the little tweaks
like that would go a long way also take
a think about it the other thing I'm
wondering about is images that aren't
rectangular
that maybe we should have a a image
should be capable of having an image
region that isn't rectangular
so that it becomes you know and I don't
know whether that means in
image collage and things like that it
could imagine doing something more like
word cloud
Etc et cetera et cetera
but I think the rectangularity I mean we
I think it's interesting here's another
related concept which is that
often
in many workflows you need
um
which is kind of like the same thing
like like a medical you you need to sort
of Mark something up and you need to
have a little bit of information about
the thing that you mark up
yeah this is a tumor you know grade A or
whatever it is
um
and I think the same thing comes up in
almost all applied workflows like remote
sensing techniques
but you indicate something and I mean we
have a region of Interest mechanism for
images yes or no
it's not baked into them
masking option is here and there
um okay but it's not baked into the
image that's what Roger and I am both
saying
right I mean maybe that's a better thing
than even having weird shaped images is
just assume the image is going to be
rectangular but have the possibility of
picking out a particular sub element sub
sub-region
it's been suggested couple of times to
use Alpha channel for that I don't like
that idea I think it has to be no angry
I agree if we're going to use a channel
let's use the PSI Channel okay
right let's not use a channel that has
another meaning exactly if if we need it
as an implementation hack we can use a
channel that you know some other channel
that we you know for example right now
we have channels one two three four why
don't we have named channels
why can't we have channels in an
association yeah we've talked about that
it's come up in like spectral Imaging
context and things like that as well
that's a good thing to do because that
way we could have a region of Interest
Channel
I think it's just a little bit of an
expensive implementation wise
um project
and maybe
it never got prioritized in in my head
well I think you should think about it
because I think that that way we could
solve this problem because that way we
could have
you know we could have the dog Channel
and things
one thing is about how how to talk about
this with the external world right for
example many image formats only accept
three channels
or for
I I mean I don't think that that's a
problem like if let's say that I think
that there are many ways to do that so
let's say that I have markups on a dicom
image
should you render those markups into the
image themselves when you export it it's
a choice
yeah
or should you ignore it sometimes you
don't right exactly
it's like a flattening operation we've
got it in some data structure and to
export its splumpf you flatten it
um
okay let's look at shape detection find
image shapes so what was updated in this
the thing that it's not yet in in the
builds but we think we can make it the
the thing that might be useful and we're
just considering adding that to this
release is to use label Matrix as though
label Matrix that you don't like
well I mean the option called by The
Matrix no as the input
So currently we have an image oh I see
you so you take a matrix as input as
well as an image right and if that
Matrix is just a bunch of integers then
we recognize the
the shapes the five shapes the fives
make up a circle or because one problem
in finding image shapes when we pass it
edges is to group the edges into uh like
connected or related components pixels
and once we go in with a label Matrix
that problem is already solved
well I don't think this that look I
think it's it's like a bunch about I
mean I don't what happens if I just say
blur of random real
one
40 40. you'll get a message
what did you expect
I wanted to take those like I wanted to
do the same algorithm that it would do
if I took this thing here no you could
do mean filter or or you know other
filters but right right right so I do
this
and then I want to blur that
and then get the Matrix back out yeah
why not I mean since it works with mean
filter how would I know that it doesn't
work with this
I I don't know Blair always sounded very
like visual it is but I mean I don't see
why it shouldn't work with these
right and I mean just like
you know and and that way that would be
an excuse to have this the image shapes
work with numbers as well so that for
example even if I have like like for
example if I say
uh
well find image shapes a little weird
but I mean and and find image shapes on
a sparse array for example oh it's just
got one
you know I mean that would be kind of
interesting to be able to find the two
lines and you know if you have some
sparse array that came from some
you know
pde-ish discretization or something and
has two lines in it
why not
you know Sanders commenting by the way
we could just use gaussian filter on the
random reels and that's true but I just
don't see why the other one shouldn't
work I mean it's not going to do
anything else
that one requires a radius
blur has a default
um i s when we talk about these
icing utilities I always wonder how many
times people intentionally intentionally
want to blur
data and how many times it might be some
kind of a coding error and they might
appreciate you know some kind of a
nervous I think it's I think this
particular case I just don't think
they're going to do it on image if they
did it on something you know it will be
because they had the numbers and they
forgot to make it into an image
mm-hmm
but
you know that would be my way of
justifying making it work on label
matrices okay
but then with real matrices we probably
have to do some kind of a gradient
filtering to
kind of segment
and in an integer Matrix the the
gradient is just a different numbers
different imagers yeah I don't know I'll
have to think about it think about it I
mean whatever we're doing for the image
itself
we should do for Phi demonstrates on a
matrix
on on images the one Behavior you didn't
like
um but we thought that's the correct one
is that we ask the user to compute the
edges and the reason why we say that is
fine image shape
yeah we're planning to allow for
different things to be highlighted and
then we can find disks as well as
circles and then us automate
automatically Computing gradient filter
might not be right at that scenario as
well
where are you Computing where are you
asking the user to compute kind of thing
um expects under the table we say
expects an image to be
in which the shapes are highlighted
and yes that gradient filter before you
find images that's horrible that's
horrible
but I mean so we should be able to do oh
gosh
you guys
polish guys
I mean maybe it wasn't technically
possible before but it is now so let's
try and make sure that we can use the
sound thing to do the segmentation so we
don't have to insist on that
so that becomes a comment and a
suggestion not a necessity
um but then
I guess okay
I still want to think about scenarios
where as we were talking about
deterministic behavior when do people
want to compute their outlines with
whatever method and then say yeah and
then right but I mean so and then say
something like pre-processing none
or something I don't know yeah something
like that but I mean it may be that the
pre-processing is so I think it will be
so good at noticing there's a purple
ring there and ignoring everything else
uh-huh
I think if we introduce some option like
that pre-processing we can use it in
many places I don't know five versions
ago
we talked about it never introduced
yeah I
I you remind me of Oliver he calls
anything that isn't solving either
pre-processing or post-processing all
right I've heard that so but it's like
enough you know for him it all means
finite element related the thing in
post-processing but I kind of don't want
to call this Edge highlighting option or
something like that although we can
squeeze it on their method option method
goes to
actually I think we do have
pre-processing sub-option in some places
okay
um
but like
although Edge detection goes to true or
false on their method
yes but look I think
okay so several comments
I don't even understand why the compass
is there by the time you've got the
purple highlighting why don't get rid of
it and just say find the you know if you
don't want
all the noise of the compass
just do your Edge detection first and do
find image shapes on the edge detected
image uh-huh as as in the example
no not as in this example I'm saying
just get purple here uh-huh right so I
mean in this case just add graphics
sure yeah I think just just I mean what
I'm saying is
just do you know we oh
you know
drives me
I'm so confused by what's going on here
just just oh there is a gradient filter
here so this is yes I hate this
oh come on why don't you just put the
image in there
bad workflow who's using it twice yep
okay so
okay
the ghost of the compass is there
now if I say find image shapes of that
how many circles is that
that's more than what's there do we have
more parameters over there
oh we're we're just picking the two
bigger ones maximal by reach and measure
two oh come on
come on guys do a better job with these
examples I mean you've got to show what
it really does did this this function I
agree should improve and as I said we
put our focus on Sam now I I think the
better Edge detection even from Sam is
gonna help better find image shapes
um and then we talked about some other
ideas here well I mean I also am not
sure that the right answer for this
isn't some kind of data set play again
oh I agree with that sure well you show
what what the actual thing was and the
picture and then
you know and then you give the actual
you give the form I'm not I'm not
certain but at least properties maybe
now that data is set by default but at
least the set of properties would make
sense
okay
okay what is in paint what's been done
with it we're going to need to come back
to a bunch of this stuff obviously yes
I'm I'm kind of have a hard stop myself
here in just a minute
okay so what are we doing within paint I
sent you some additional
um notebooks that you don't have in the
docs
so the thing we're adding here just like
Sam can pick out the component if we
specify a position or a rectangle and
then segment that piece now we are
saying previously in pain they expected
an image that highlighted what's being
impainted but just look at those few
tentative examples you can give it a
point and it gets rid of the segment
indicated by that point by that
rectangle set of rectangles and so forth
so I it's just Auto segmenting
again the problem when we do that
it requires downloading the network and
a few seconds of running the network to
do the segmentation well downloading the
network is fine
I mean in the cloud it'll be
pre-downloaded and we need to make sure
that's the case and you know people I I
do think
that as we have more stuff that requires
downloading but there's we should
discuss the possibility of a giant sort
of download panel okay where you know
something in the preferences for example
which says what to pre-download
because I can imagine a situation where
somebody I don't know they're running
some class or something and they want to
send everybody a pre-download
sort of manifest so people can run it
and it grinds away in the background for
an hour and then they show up and then
they can do everything
assets resources needed for different
function again I think was discussed a
while ago yeah well right but I mean I
think I think but putting that in the
preferences
as something that should be background
downloaded
to that computer makes some sense to me
I hadn't really thought of putting it in
preferences before now look I mean I
think um
uh
you know monk with a with a
umbrella or whatever the heck this is
maybe they're not monks I don't know
what they are well I think they are this
is very low resolution
um but they look like that the uh
okay but in any case I mean
presumably this could be a name here of
a thing right the prompted version of
all of these
um is probably as well a 14-1 project
right I understand I understand but I
mean the other thing we should be able
to do is to one once we have image
contents and one of these monks is
extracted as one of the sub-images one
should be able to say in paint this
thing comma the monk because you should
easily be able to find the monk in the
image and we have a function for doing
that don't we right
I mean if we don't I'm gonna have to go
I'm gonna ask to set up one more hour
right
because we have also audio we have input
export not super much in either one but
and and wrap what we started
yes okay fine okay
all right see you Roger we'll we'll wrap
in just a second here
um
what
what has been modernized and text
recognized not much in the ref page but
if you open uh the benchmarks
more specifically so far we have
improved natural
in this one
the typo
it's it always amuses me how quickly you
see typo Stephen
um so both both the improvements are in
natural scene text detection or text
recognition but we are moving forward
with
um ezocr a set of networks that are
known to be good performing as well and
then updating possibly printed text and
other languages as well you some of
those that second number for fine image
text is not that it's still a big
Improvement but not as big as the first
one you were seeing Tesseract was
performing like 21 accurate on natural
scenes before and now we're getting
I think 70 80 if you scroll up that's
good
yep
I assume it performs I before I assume
the new thing performs with the same
time performance and
as high accuracy on a printed page for
example on a scan right uh well we do
want to run a benchmark before we switch
the back end and that easy OCR that I
said is also a very promising back end
for printed text okay but we can we can
surely run a incredibly cheap classifier
for whether we're looking at a natural
scene or printed text if we need to
switch between them yes
that's more of the future stuff text
related can we do handwriting OCR is
that is that is that advanced
you pause that project I think
a year or two years ago
we haven't got back gotten back to that
but I I think it's something that we
could potentially get back but I just
don't know whether it will work yet I
mean I've got tons of examples if you
want them from
which one is higher priority you think
math or handwritten
I agree
all right well we should uh
uh
what is that
um wait that is not uh for that speech
synthesize
that does not right recognize using the
OS recognizer the OS apis is not a 14
feature anymore likely not good 14.
is that local or is it going to the
cloud so I think it depend on Mac it
most likely goes to the cloud but apple
is a bit fishy about it how to do how
they document this they they aren't
really explicit if it goes to their
cloud or not
so uh this is why we're kind of
postponing to make sure we have all of
these details okay under control
all right we should wrap for now
um
looks good look forward to the next
iteration here okay thank you okay see
you all soon
thanks